i remember they they came into school
and they did like this presentation one
time because this
we i oscar wasn't a like christian
school or anything
yeah but we did pray three times a day
and every single story had to be a
[ __ ] bible story
right so i thought that was kind of sad
but anyway they would i remember this
one story they told
out just stuck out my mind and i hated
this story so much i thought this was
the dumbest [ __ ] story okay
they would be like what do you want for
christmas you could have
five pounds or a bible and and it was
like
everyone the first person chose the five
pounds
and they got given the five pounds yeah
and they were happy the second person
got asked for the five pounds and they
got the five pounds
and they didn't want the bible the third
person they chose the bible
and when they opened the bible up there
was 10 pounds in it
and i was like what is the moral of this
story
like even when i was a kid i'm like are
you trying to tell me
that every bible has a tenor in it
because i'm going to go around and look
and there was no tenors and i'm like
wait so
so what is the moral like genuinely now
like what is the moral of this story
like even even ten-year-old me was like
this is dumb this is really dumb it's
like that's like
that's like and then they were trying to
be like choosing knowledge
over money is more i'm like
the bible's like three pounds so wait
hold up so what are you
like i'm like and we can't guarantee
there's always gonna be money in the
bible
so technically if i get the bible i take
the tenor out and i sell the bible for
three pounds exactly you know 13 pounds
i was i was just like this is dumb this
is a dumb dump shame on you you could
have
yes you're so lazy i know i'm a kid but
this is so and this annoyed the [ __ ] out
of me and they told this thing like
three times
in my whole school yeah and every single
time i used to get like seethingly mad
when they would tell this story and no
one else seemed bothered by it they were
like yeah that's a good moral
this is a dumb dumb moral this this is
never a situation you would be who asks
you which gift you want
no no and it's never going to be between
money and a book it's all you've seen
what do you want for your birthday do
you want money or this it's like
maybe the money yeah what is this choice
but it's it's never a
it's never a philosophical question of
which do i want i'm just going to take
the thing that you you that i want this
shouldn't be a [ __ ] like
a question of my moral standing you're
giving me a gift for christmas [ __ ] off
it's like christmas it's like which one
do you want but just millionaire music
they're really annoying
it's just the whole i i i really really
really really really despise when they
try
it's really weird when they try and turn
very
un-religious situations or philosophical
situations into philosophical situations
yeah
that should have no right to be i'm like
i'm just trying to buy my homie a
present i want to know what they want
like genuinely i'm trying to be a good
friend if if god wants to five pounds
that's what god wants i'ma give him the
five pounds yeah who am i to preach that
god wants to [ __ ] bible bro he
doesn't want that [ __ ] like
maybe he's not religious you know what i
mean i'm not trying to save him what is
this [ __ ] you want five pounds are you
sure about that
i got a bible and every year i got older
and they would tell the story
i would get more annoyed by it the more
i realized how little sense it made
this whole i don't know if this is a
common thing or something they just told
in my school but they would tell this
story all the time i mean i went to a
catholic high school and i've
never heard of that story i don't know
if it's something that they made up and
this is like that banger that they kept
in
like they're like the person telling the
story
this is the story that gets people that
to like discover christ
it's like you're not a christian yet oh
just and i remember one time connor
tell him the bible story come on come on
come on one time as well
because they used to tell my primary
school and i remember because i
i this is the one that really pissed me
off like i just i just remembered this
right now
is that the headmaster of my high school
because
it was a primary school to the the
elementary school who told it twice
throughout the elementary school i
remember this because i always hated it
so oixed it out
and then i i remember it my head
my prime uh the sub headmaster came in
and
he [ __ ] came in and he started
talking about it i'm like no
don't you dare tell the story and he had
the audacity
to bring in both the props as well oh my
god
and he couldn't just tell the story yeah
he had to ask the kids which one they
wanted
yeah and it backfired because the first
kid he asked was from the same
primary school as me yeah so he he knew
the answer yeah yeah
and so he asked which one do you want
the bible or the five pounds for
christmas and he was like bible
immediately and he was like which one do
you really want
bible and he had to be like good answer
that's the correct correct answer
because there's a tenor in there to
reward you
yeah i'm like [ __ ] off oh [ __ ] off bro i
hate this
this sucks i hate this you know this
made me more
not this just made me despise religion
even more
from a young age this is not the way to
get kids into religion exactly
like there's better ways to do like it's
literally just tricking them right and
just being like yeah this
like kind of untrue unrealistic thing
happens all the time
take the bite there's just so many of
these religious things that when you
actually break them down a real scenario
just don't work
in a way that you're like just stop just
stop yeah i don't mind people religion
and all that yeah of course
yeah but there's a better way to get
changed with these stories like this
just know exactly i can't wait for like
a [ __ ]
jehovah's witness like knock on your
door and you open it and you just see
the bible
i'm just like a thousand again in the
other hand you're just like no
no
it's like how sweet just like just shake
shake it shake it shake the bible
just grab the
morals are stealing right yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah
tomorrow i'm sorry take the bible
because that is there's a tenor in there
yeah i always take the bible questions
every bible you see has a tenor in this
song
in any other situation just take the
five hours unless you want to take the
bike i don't need religion to tell me
not to be an [ __ ] i'm already doing
that frankly i'm trying my best because
you know
when the man in the taxi offered me the
money or the bible i took the money
it was all a setup it was all a setup
what kills me is like what christian out
there who's who is like
not who is already a christian doesn't
already own a bible like either right
who out there who just posed this
question be like
you know what i was just looking for a
bible actually
i needed a seventh copy of the bible in
the house i'll take the tenor as well
thank you very much
this is this has been like one of the
weirdest tangents
starting off season two strong i can see
my god i just
always know me i'm still annoyed about
it to this day when i go back if i ever
go to school i'm not gonna give a shitty
talk
i'm gonna i should do an even worse one
than that i'm gonna you know you know
what you should do you know what i'm
gonna do like
if i ever have a kid i'm going to tell
that story you should to my kid but
not put the tenor in the bible
but like you're dumb there's one of
these in every single hotel you could've
got one for free you're not a [ __ ]
hustler
should have taken the five